Hello, Lin Chen,...
...Sales Manager for National Sugar.
And my associate, Jon Marton.
Very pleased to meet you. I'm Victor Tang and this is my legal adviser Sue Peney.
I hope you had a pleasant flight over.
Yes, we did. Thanks.
Are you staying for a few days?
Unfortunately, we need to get back to Manila tomorrow.
Well, we'd better get down to business.
Mr. Tang, to start off with,....
...I just want to say we believe we could offer you a very good deal...
...and come up with a win-win result.
Well, from our point of view, we see it as an exploratory talk.
Testing the water you might say.
We don't intend to reach any agreements at this meeting.
In any case, we would need to run it past our board first.
You haven't heard our terms yet.
You may find them hard to resist.
Of course, we understand you need time to consider any offer.
My first priority is to keep the negotiations open.
What's your proposal, Ms. Chen?
We're prepared to offer a very attractive price for a minimum sale...
...in exchange for a two-year contract.
Jon will clarify the terms.